everyone's heard about Shane Gillis
signing with Bud Light that guy that we
met the CEO he's got it together yeah he
gets it I thought you were the CEO now
just in
commercial but Shane wasn't the only
comedian to make a big-time alcohol
announcement last week as Burke rer and
Tom sagora launched their own vodka
brand called porosos which translates in
Spanish to four Bears I was pretty
adamant about vodka I love the word oos
and Tom's fluent in Spanish and when he
said it it just sounded like it wanted
to be in my mouth you know how like
Latino guys just have their way with you
is that how you feel we want our vodka
to have its way with you yeah and I
think it's going to this move is super
unbrand for the Bears especially given
Bert's love for vodka and the comedy
alcohol game as a whole is seemingly
taking off right now in general from
Mark Norman and samarel to Ron White and
by now